bienvenue à l'île de france fait le
théâtre sur la base de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines
l'île de france fait le théâtre c'est un
événement initié et financé par la
région ile de france est organisé par
les tréteaux de france centre dramatique
national
on propose des activités autour de la
création théâtrale des ateliers de
pratique artistique pour tous les âges
et tous les publics des spectacles jeune
public des spectacles tout public
le tout entièrement gratuit et ouvert à
tous
[Musique]
d'aller à la rencontre du public c'est à
dire de proposer des spectacles de
grande qualité à des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de venir au théâtre et donc
de leur proposer à la fois le spectacle
d'être spectateur est à la fois des
tracteurs puisqu'ils peuvent jouer et
pratiquer le théâtre
[Musique]
c'est un programme très varié donc on a
des ateliers les ateliers commencent à
14h30 ensuite on a des spectacles jeune
public l'homme de fer tout public les
trois mousquetaires et le spectacle du
soir sous le grand chapiteau qui est
derrière moi phèdre de jean racine mise
en scène par robin renucci une fois la
mare asséchée dans le fond l'étranger a
vu une forme une masse énorme couverte
de boue une boue couleurs de rouille on
aurait dit un corps le corps d'un homme
de fer il mesure près de 3 m
sa chevelure couvre son visage son torse
et jusqu'à ses cuisses de son visage on
ne voit qu'un oeil un seul
fermé
[Musique]